you smoked pot with Charlie Manson This
is a true story my friend James Jeremiah
I'm still friends with this day we went
to college together he lived in
Chatsworth I lived in uh Northridge and
he said I'm want to visit my friend Dave
he's lives in this treehouse now and
he's doing this incredible art so we
went to his place and he did indeed live
in a treehouse next door to a saloon and
so we went and visited him up in the
treeh house he did this beautiful art he
was uh he was on uh speed at some point
he did this crazy art and we were out of
dope well let's walk up to the main
house and smoke a joint I think they
have some pot up there we did there a
bunch of hippies nothing really
noteworthy one of them recognized my
name my father's name said oh your dad's
in the business I know can you help me
had some songs or something you want
people to hear but I didn't know a lot
of music people then so we left went
back to the car I probably should have
mentioned the Treehouse was next door to
not a real Saloon but a fake Saloon at a
SP uh a movie set street called the
spawn Ranch if that name rings the bell
well you're too young to for it to ring
a bell but it does with howy that was do
you know what the spawn Ranch was no do
you know does anybody back there Jeremy
what is the spawn Ranch yeah it was a
char Charles Manson's like headquarters
right yeah they they squatted there
right didn't they they did they squatted
there they kind of enticed and drugged
the guy I can't remember the name of the
old guy that kind of ran the place he
was a caretaker for the spawn Ranch but
they basically kept him a hostage and a
year later then we discovered who we
smoked a joint with because they
pictures from in the paper wait a minute
that's a guy that had the music that was
Charlie and Tex Watson there's Linda and
there's you know caban well I know
because I watched what's the most recent
movie that came out that was about that
once upon it not once upon a time in
hollyw oh Hollywood the yeah yeah they
did a pretty good job of capturing the
essence I don't know if they shot at the
spawn wrench who which movie was that
Tarantino's movie Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood is that what it was called
yeah once upon a time in Hollywood and
they showed the ranch so I'm assuming it
looked knowing Quint turno they must
have got to the real ranch or recreated
it at that site yeah but it's uh yeah it
was definitely all those people they
were in the newspaper and I had a pretty
good memory at that point when these are
the same people we definitely I call it
my friend James and I missing something
he said no this this is the gang we
smoked the joint with so from the time
you smoked the joint and was he did
Charlie play his music for you he did
not if he did I didn't it was so
unnoteworthy I didn't remember it or you
were so high that that's true too how is
it there's nothing that stood out about
there's nothing that stood out about
that moment like when you were there you
didn't feel creeped out or thought it
was weird it was creepy it was very
creepy and I didn't know why I didn't I
thought it was just bad pot yeah later I
poked I smoked pot up at this house in
belir and I thought this place was
creepy it was a place where the Tate
Loban the Tate murders J Sebring and
Sharon Tate were murdered cuz fin this
guy said well yeah I'm Rudy alelly we
haven't met before we're playing cards I
went oh my God this is the house I can
confirmed later with the address that
was the house wait so you smoked pot
with the Mastermind and then I and the
girl who who who was uh charged with the
the squeaky and what's her name squeaky
FR I don't know if she was there at that
point I think she came Watson was there
right I believe so the guy I belied to
be Tex Watson when we saw the pictures a
year later it it looked like all the
same people so you not only smoked pot
with the people planning to do the
murders you smoked pot at the place the
murders took place I don't know I didn't
no this was the 80s so I wasn't smoking
pot at that time but I was playing poker
in this house and I discovered it was
Rudy alabi's house and I believe he was
the owner of the house he did not live
there he rented it out he was the owner
of the house where it occurred I'm
pretty sure I think you go back I think
Jeff Franklin uh uh um Bob Saget's um
Memorial was at Jeff Franklin's house
and Jeff Franklin who's the creator of
Full House do you know Jeff I've met him
I think through Bob I love Bob what a
great guy he was yeah I will miss him
but he he he that's the house he bought
that where is that that's up at the it's
up Belair if I saw the name of the
street I'd remember it he bought that
house and we we were in the H you told
me yeah yeah and I went there with John
Stamos and John Stamos said that him and
uh who would buy that house Jeff
Franklin well well he he knocked down
the house but it's it's got an amazing
view they knocked it down it had a weird
vibe somebody look up if you can Rudy
albelli I don't know how you spell that
see if he was indeed the owner of the
house Drive C drive do you remember
that's it that's it it's definitely clo
Drive definitely and I definitely played
poker at a house on a very short street
it's not a Long Street at all clo Drive
I I I uh I mean I yeah I played poker
there so I I was so you were in the
actual house I was in the actual house
later on this is like very disconnected
from the time you smoked pop with
Charlie Manson and years later from 69 I
smoked pot with him in 68 it all came to
light in August I think of' 69 yeah I've
been in some weird places it's not me is
it I'm not causing these things to
happen am
I